Let's take a minute to look at reliability in blackboard architectures.
In a blackboard architecture,
the independence of the components can increase system resilience.
That is, the system may continue to function in a degraded fashion if one of
its components breaks.
On the other hand, because there is no overall definition of system behavior, it
may be difficult to identify the cause of a problem when something goes wrong.
As far as an advantage is concerned, access control and
the blackboard architecture's enhanced because there's a common data repository.
On the other hand,
the flexibility of a blackboard architecture allows for the dynamic condition of
new components which may reduce confidence in overall system security.